hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well another thing
that comes out of this
what are we trying to work out if we're
not working out the body
Epictetus box abounds rationale
sometimes he falls in the will
do another thing so this is finally all
okay so here's a question that you can
ask yourself that you know we've looked
at a couple times in the psychics class
what is the most important part of you
what is the best part of you as a human
being as a person and Epictetus is an
answer for this and it's kind of similar
to the one that Plato and to a lesser
extent Aristotle had it's this this
rational part of you the court that's
distinctively human you have other parts
of you that are more animalistic that
you share in common with the other
animals even in some degree of the
plants you know I mean plants breathe
you breathe that's not what makes you
human
this ruling part is where we actually
have the possibility of changing our
opinions our judgments our desires our
ways of looking at things so you notice
I place desires and aversions down here
they are really tied in with this as
well and so are our beliefs and our
opinions and our genders you're going to
have desires and aversions and beliefs
and judgments from the start by the time
you start thinking about these things
the question is what are you going to do
with them are they good enough as they
are you just follow them and try to make
them work out as best you can
or should you actually like call them
into question and think about whether
they're the right believes they have the
right desires together and he talks
about this not so much in the end
karidian but in in the discourses
he says what's a person what's a human
being so one of the classic definition
is irrational and she says by the
reactional faculty what are we separated
from well from the other handles right
so he says from wild beasts from what
else what other order other Kensie we
have wild animals domestic animals right
and he's being very metaphorical here
but this is kind of good to keep in mind
he says take care of them to do nothing
like a wild beast but if you do you've
lost the character of a human being
you've not fulfilled your promise see
that you do nothing like a sheep but if
you do in that case the person is washed
what does it t act like a sheep that
doesn't mean just to follow you know in
conformity we often talk about sheep
that way right know the person's a sheep
and they just accept everybody else's
opinions it's not just that it has to do
with your desires
he says when we act lot initially when
we act lewdly rashly inconsiderately
what have we declined to so when we're
acting in ways in which we just follow
our you know basic desires you know he
says gluttonously what does it want me
about hi yeah more broadly food Furi
Furi one who's only obsessed with pie
then you're probably not that bad off
but yeah food lewdly would be about
lustily would be about what the second
very good sexual desire when we have
inconsiderately that's more
inattentiveness father other people he
says what what have we declined it we
were like sheep though we've lost the
rational faculty when we act here's
another different part of ourselves when
we act contentiously and harmfully and
passionately and violently what is that
so doesn't that sound a lot like Plato's
two months you know this part of us that
gets angry
the part that went with which we get
offended if we indulge that then what
are we decline to do says to wild beasts
consequently some of us are great wild
beasts and others little beasts but if
we do this then the distinctively human
part of us is being lost
bit by bit by bit by bit not all at once
but slowly over time through habits and
he says well how do you actually
maintain things why don't you know how
do you maintain a flute or a liar in our
case we would probably say how do you
maintain a guitar or a piano how do you
preserve a horse or a dog well you have
to treat it the right way you have to
take the things that are you know
distinctive about it and focus in on
those and attend to those features and
see that it gets the things that it
needs so you know can you keep piano in
good condition if you just you know jump
on it bang on it all the time or like
pour drinks into it probably you know
can you can you feed your dog Cheerios
and beer all the times it's all good
probably eat it it's not gonna be very
good for the dog I'm sure there's
something who's done that somewhere yeah
that's not the way to maintain you have
to actually you know look at what it is
that you're trying to maintain and
what's distinctive about it and then
exercise that part and then feed that
part well what is it for a human being
he says well you don't think about
different kinds of human beings or
different professions how do you get
better at carpentry if you decide you
want to be a carpenter I'm not a very
good trades people how would I get
better go to carpentry school yeah a lot
of these things you actually learn know
you I could just do it wouldn't it be
better if I actually did it with
somebody
say man you're off there yeah so we view
apprentice with somebody else
what about grammar how do you learn
grammar well you apprentice with
somebody who's a grammarian if you want
to learn philosophy study with people
who know philosophy if you want to learn
in social work study with some other
people write to know something about
sociable if you want to get good at a
sport yeah there are coaches for that
right if you're working with a coach and
you're not actually getting better
there's probably something wrong with
the colors and you could go on and on
with this so what about this part of you
that really makes you you says if you
want to develop that and you need to
find the people who actually focus on
and you need to exercise it and you need
to feed it so let's look at some of the
things that he says about this stuff is
ruling part says of all the faculties
you'll find not one which is capable of
contemplating itself and they're not
capable either of disapproving or
approving so if you think about Grandma
for example the grammatical arm you've
all mastered that actually because
you've got all right grammatical English
sentences good how much does that arts
does that piece of you inside of
yourself that bit of knowledge can
grammar actually like analyze itself can
look at itself they can tell you whether
you're in grammar or out of grammar
whether you're abiding by its rules or
not abiding by its rules right can
grammar actually tell you whether you
should study grammar
no can it can carpentry tell you whether
you should use carpentry no can
carpentry like rethink itself and figure
out how I should change it's making an
assumption from the start but you
yourself
and you're able to think about this
should you be a carpenter should you
learn carpentry should you study grammar
should you work on this assignment or
not work on this assignment should you
take this class or not take this class
should your life go in this direction or
in this direction should you date this
person or date this person or maybe not
date anybody at all should you go on
that trip or not if you go on that trip
what are you deciding that you want to
come out of that trip where are you
going to to decide to go on your and
your day trips all of those things you
actually do decide don't you that's not
grammar or carpentry or even you know I
suppose an art of traveling that decides
that it's this rational part of you so
he says well what faculty does actually
you know tell you about what you want to
do the one that contemplates itself and
other things if you haven't thought up
until this point about whether your life
is going in the right direction or
whether you have the right habits or
whether your beliefs and your desires
are in line with reality you are now
more likely to disappoint you if you
haven't done those things then you're
not using this to its full capacity yet
that materials would say that's the bad
news but the good news is you can
actually do this if you decide at this
point in your life that you wanted to do
something different with your life you
want to make your life focus you've
previously focused it around saying
enjoyment pleasure and now you want to
focus it on something that you
considered about it that's within your
faculty of choice isn't it and you can
actually understand that that's part of
this rational faculty so he says the
rational faculty examines itself what it
is what power it has and what is the
value of this and it examines all the
other types so what should you do it for
success
well this ruling party has sort of
preconceptions
about what's good or bad what's right or
wrong
what's rational or irrational and the
goal is to get those rights so the first
thing that you have to do with it is
actually look at what do you think about
these things and you probably have to do
that in reaction by observing yourself
over time that's not something you can
sit down and do as an assignment one
time for all once you've actually
started doing that quite often you'll
notice mistakes or blemishes or blind
spots or this you know sort of errors in
your understanding of what's good and
bad right everyone rational or
irrational
you'll also observe it in other people
too and once you start doing that you
can stir that gives you an incredible
freedom because you can say to yourself
hey do I want to do I want to stick with
this do I want to keep doing things
thinking about things this way so you
can take your desires you can't change
them just like that say well I'm not
going to desire this anymore but you can
actually ask yourself is this desire a
rational one for me to have is this
desire one that's likely to lead me to
unhappiness or the chance of unhappiness
or is this a desire that's actually good
for me to have if it's a desire that's
bad for you to have how do you change
your desires well you change the way
that you think about things you change
the way that you view things and judge
them so again that's the rational
faculties sort of purifying itself
getting itself back on track you don't
start out with a rational faculty I
think that pettiness would say that's
completely rational that's completely in
line with the way it could be they ought
to be it's something you have to work on
over
the course of your life that's probably
enough about the rational faculty